Transcriber: AHMET GÜRSU
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Av. Feyza Altun
Aktivist
Kadın erkek eşit mi?
Eşit değilsek niye değiliz?
Eşitsek niye sürekli
ayrımcılığa uğruyoruz?
Bu çoğumuzun yaptığı bir tartışma muhakkak
kendi kadın erkek ilişkimizde,
arkadaş ortamlarında.
Hukuk kurallarına baktığımız zaman
hukuken de eşitiz aslında.
Yani kanunda eşit gözüküyoruz.
Fakat Dünya Ekonomi Forumu'nun 2016'da
yaptığı cinsiyet eşitliği raporuna göre,
kadın ve erkeğin iş hayatında
temsil edilmesi için
sizce kaç sene gerekiyor olabilir?
Eşit olmamız için?
Çok hızlı birkaç tane
fikir almak istiyorum.
Var mı fikriniz?
93, iyi yaklaştınız.
117 sene gerekiyor.
Eşitiz diyen lütfen bu örneği hatırlasın.
Yani 117 sene sonra ancak iş hayatında,
eşit bir şekilde temsil edileceğiz.
Baktığınız zaman sorumluluk anlamında da
eşit gibi gözüküyoruz.
Kadınların pek çok özgürlüğü
var gibi gözüküyor.
Ama baktığınız zaman bir yerde
yine bir sıkıntı var.
Şimdi kadın erkek beraber sabah
kalkıyorlar, işe gidiyorlar.
Birisi doğalgazı ödüyorsa, birisi
elektrik faturasını ödüyor.
Beraber çıkılacak tatilin
faturaları beraber ödeniyor.
Ya da onun için beraber
para biriktiriliyor.
Fakat kadının gelenekten gelen görevi
evde devam ediyor.
İkisi aynı anda çalışıyorlar,
aynı eşit maaşı kazanıyorlar.
İkisi de yoruluyor, eve geliyorlar.
Adam televizyonun önüne oturuyor
ya da Playstation oynuyor.
Kadın sofrayı kuruyor,
yemek yapıyor, sofrayı topluyor,
çocuk varsa çocuklarla ilgileniyor,
ütü varsa ütü yapıyor, çamaşır yıkıyor,
bebek varsa gece kalkıyor,
adam çok prensipli kendini hiç bozmuyor
hâlâ Playstation oynuyor.
Devam ediyor buna .
Alkışlar, kadınlar alkışlıyor arkadan.
(Alkışlar)
Devam ediyor,
durun daha bitmedi geliyoruz.
Ve bu kısır döngü devam ediyor.
Bir noktadan sonra kadın
iflas ediyor artık.
Çünkü; bu bir robot değil, bu bir canlı.
O da yoruluyor,
o da para kazanıyor ama evde de bu
şeyleri devam ettirmek durumunda kalıyor.
Kadın bir noktadan sonra ben bunları
yapmak istemiyorum dediği zaman,
erkek sorgulamaya başlıyor.
Kadınlık görevleri,
erkeklik görevleri devreye giriyor.
Boşanmalarda bunlar kimi zaman
ortaya çıkarılıyor.
Bunlar kadının görevi olarak
kabul ediliyor.
Kadın bunları otomatikman kendisi
içşelleştirmiş oluyor.
Hâliyle ilişkilerde sıkıntılar başlıyor.
Ben burada kadına da erkeğe de kızmıyorum.
Çünkü bunlar bize çok küçüklükten
empoze edilen şeyler.
Eğitimle de alakası yok.
Eğitim bunu biraz kırıyor ancak,
kadınlar ve erkeklerde.
Bu ülkede "Göster oğlum amcana pipini"
kültürü var mesela.
İhtişamlı bir şey olsa anlayacağım
sürekli gösterilmesini.
Ama neden o pipi sürekli sergileniyor
onu hiç anlamıyorum.
"Göster oğlum amcalara pipini,"
"aç oğlum pipini,"
"oğlum pipini çağır yemek yesin."
Pipi bir kişilik çünkü, böyle bir kişilik
atfediliyor ona.
Çocuk haklı.
Bir süre sonra bunu bir şey sanıyor,
pipisini göstermesi gerektiğini düşünüyor.
Sonra biz kadınlar diyoruz ki, erkekler
niye böyle ya, acaba niye böyleler?
Küçükten geliyor bunlar.
Kız çocuklarında da tam tersi.
Sen kızsın yapmamalısın.
Yapamazsın. Yapmayacaksın.
Sen bu bölümü okuyamazsın.
Sen böyle gülemezsin.
Sen bunu giyinemezsin.
Sen bunu yapamazsın.
Erkekleri cinsellikleriyle ne kadar övüp
performanslarıyla ne kadar onu
bir toplumda yer edindiriyorsak,
kadınları da kendi cinselliklerinden
o kadar utandırıyoruz.
Daha ergenliğinden başlıyor erkeklerin,
seviştin mi?
Kaç kişiyle seviştin? Nasıl seviştin?
Ne zaman seviştin?
Kızlara da tam tersi,
aman kızım sevişmesin.
Ya bir mantık hatası var burada şimdi.
Adam sevişsin, kız?
Ya adam kimle şevişecek her şeyden önce?
Sıkıntı var yani burada.
Bak erkekler alkışlıyor galiba,
işinize geliyor galiba değil mi konu.
Burada benim anlamadığım mantık
hatası var baktığınız zaman.
Ama, bunu böyle söylediğimiz zaman
evet komik oluyor, komik çünkü.
Ama gerçek hayatta yaşananlar
tabii ki de çok farklı.
Bu masallardan başlıyor aslında.
Masallara baktığımız zaman şimdi;
Pamuk Prenses,
Uyuyan Güzel,
Rapunzel.
Bunlara bakın, bu kadınlar
hep kapalı bir yerde,
cam fanusta,
bir yerde izole bir yerdedirler.
Çünkü bu izolasyon aslında
nedir biliyor musunuz?
Bize ne mesaj veriliyor?
Onlara el değmiyor, onlar bakire.
Ve kim açacak o cam fanusu?
Ejderhayı kim kıracak?
Onunla evlenecek olan prens.
Evliliğin kutsallığı, kocanın kutsallığı
ve orada, onlar izole şekilde
kadının yaşıyor olması,
yine o bekaretin temsili.
Aslında bize alttan alttan bu
mesajları veriyor.
Bir de bakın, bu kadınların
hep ortak özellikleri vardır.
Hepsi çok güzel.
Hiç konuşmuyorlar.
Erkeklerin en sevdiği.
Kendilerine ne kötülük yapılırsa yapılsın,
hiç itiraz etmeyecek kadar
salak kadınlar bunlar.
Hiçbir şey söylemiyorlar.
Yani başlarına bin bir türlü bela geliyor,
hep böyle bekliyor, cüceler falan.
Böyle mutlu mutlu takılıyor bu kadınlar.
Bu nedir?
Başına ne gelirse gelsin,
kadın olarak ne yaşarsan yaşa,
sus,
kabul et,
cefakâr ol,
vefakâr ol.
Sonunda sana büyük bir şey vadediliyor.
Evlilik,
evleneceksin,
yakışıklı prens.
Erkekler yakışıklı değilseniz
bittiniz zaten.
Sizin de öyle bir handikapınız var
masallara göre.
Devamında sadece bu değil birinci
algımıza işlenen şey.
Cadılar kim masallarda hiç farkettiniz mi?
Adamların ikinci karıları.
(Gülüşmeler)
İkinci kez evlenen var mı içinizde?
Burada yine söylenen şey şu;
ilk evlilik kutsaldır.
Evleneceksiniz ve boşanmayacaksınız.
Boşanmak kötüdür ve ilk evlilik kutsaldır.
İkinci kadın ya da
ikinci evlilik o evlilik
kurumunun kutsallığını bozuyor aslında.
Bize bunlar o kadar derinden işleniyor ki,
biz bir noktadan sonra bunları
içselleştiriyoruz.
Bakın, kırmızı başlıklı kız.
Kırmızı başlıklı kız annesinin sözünü
dinlemediği için,
ormana girdiği için kurt
tarafından yeniyor.
Bu da yine bilinçaltı bir mesaj.
Sonra, bazı kahramanlık
masallarında şu var;
genelde erkekler savaşta ölmüş oluyor,
kadınların savaşa gitmesi gerekiyor.
Kadınlar savaşta erkek kılığında.
Aslanlar gibi cenk ediyorlar aslında
kadınlar ama erkek kılığındalar.
Fakat masal bu ya,
kadın yanındakine âşık oluyor.
Savaştan döneceğim, bir aşk olacak,
bir romantizm olacak illa orada.
Savaştan dönünce, yanında savaştığı
adamla evleniyor.
Adam açısından biraz sıkıntılı.
Kimle evlendin?
Asker arkadaşımla evlendim.
Savaşta, yoğun stres altında biz âşık
olduk yanlışlıkla silah arkadaşımla.
Bir mantıksızlık var ama kadına
hep böyle bir şey yükleniyor.
Hep şu mesaj veriliyor;
dış dünya erkeklere ait bir dünya.
Biz kadınlar içeride olmak
durumundayız, zorundayız.
Bu bizim görevimizdir
ve dışarıda daha çok erkek
kılığında olabiliriz.
Yani, bu masallardaki dışarıda olanlar
hep erkek kılığında olduğu için bizim de,
erkek kılığında dış dünyada
olmamız gerekiyor.
Bugün baktığınız zaman, iş hayatında
yoğun çalışan kadınlar neden eleştirilir?
Erkeksi tavırları yüzünden eleştirilir.
Erkek kılığında değiliz ama öz eleştiri
yapacağım, erkeksi tavırlarımız var.
Peki niye?
Bir öz eleştiri siz de yapın.
"Merhaba nasılsınız?" diyorsun adama,
"Nasıl olduğumu akşam yemekte
konuşalım istersen" diyor.
Yani, "Selamün aleyküm birader" demem mi
gerekiyor illa beni ciddiye alman için?
Kadınları iş hayatında ciddiye alınmak
için erkeksi tavırlara mecbur ediyorlar.
Kim yapıyor bunu?
Erkekler yapıyor.
O zaman erkeklerin burada öz eleştiri
yapması gerekiyor.
Ben iş hayatında ciddiye alınmak için
erkeksi tavırlar sergilemek zorunda
kalmak istemiyorum açıkçası.
Bu noktada yine şuna geliyoruz;
kadınlara yöneltilen eleştirilerde
aslında kadınların suçu yok,
kadınlara ben burada kızamam.
Yine toplumun getirdiği
ataerkil kurallara ve
dayattığı şeylere kızıyorum aslında ben.
Çünkü masallardan bu yana geliyor ve
gündelik hayatımızda bütün bu şeyler aynı
şekilde devam ediyor.
Baktığınız zaman alın yine,
her zaman bizim tabumuz olan,
çünkü bu coğrafyada cinsellik;
erkek cinselliği yaşasın,
kadın cinselliği yaşamasın.
Ama siz kadına sevişmediği zaman
''Kezban'' diyorsunuz.
Seviştiği zaman ''kaşar'' diyorsunuz.
Bu kadın ne yapsın?
Ne yapacak yani, bana bir onu söyleyin.
Nasıl var olacak?
Sizin onayınızı ya da sizin
takdirinizi nasıl alacak bu kadın.
Çünkü her yaptığını eleştiriyorsunuz.
Yapamazsın, edemezsinlerle
büyütüyorsunuz
ve sonra sen bunu yapamıyorsun
diye onu suçluyorsunuz.
Bir kadın iş hayatında,
eğer çocuk doğurduğu zaman çocuğuna
bakmak için işini bıraktığında,
zaten kendisi bırakmasa da iznini
kullandırmadan işten çıkarıyorlar.
Peki siz, bu kadın evde oturup çocuk
baktığı zaman kocası dâhil geliyor;
''Sen de ev hanımısın, evde oturuyosun''.
Sanki ev hanımlığı çok ciddi bir
yoğun emek gerektirirken
ve bence çok önemli bir işken,
sen bu kadına kendini
değersiz hissettiriyorsun.
Toplumda var olmasının sebebini ancak
çalışıyor olması olarak lanse ediyorsun.
Bu kadın ne yapsın?
Evde çocuğuna bakıyor sana yaranamıyor.
Dışarıda çalışıyor,
ne biçim kadın diyorsun.
Bakıcıya bırakıyor,
ne pis anne bakıcıya bırakmış diyorsun.
Kreşe vermiş, ama kreşlerde çocukları
dövüyorlar diyorsun.
Bu kadın ne yapsın?
Biz bu kadına hiçbir şekilde yaşam
alanı vermiyoruz, tanımıyoruz
ve sonrasında da ondan kendisi olmasını,
mutlu olmasını, bir birey olmasını,
dayatılan hiçbir şey yokmuş kafasında,
sınırları yokmuş gibi
yaşamasını bekliyoruz.
Bu çok mümkün bir şey değil bence.
Bir örnek vereceğim size.
Bir gün bir müvekkilim aradı.
Dedi ki Feyza Hanım;
"Bizim bir arkadaşımız
iyi bir avukat sordu sizi söyledik,
telefonunuzu verelim mi?" dedi,
verin dedim.
Telefonum çaldı "Avukat Feyyaz Bey ile
görüşebilir miyim?" dedi.
Buna çok alışığım.
Duruşmaya giriyorum, eve geliyorum,
ofise geliyorum, bakıyorum Avukat Fevzi,
Avukat Feyyaz, Avukat Feyzi.
Böyle şeyler oluyor, o yüzden de çok
yanlış anlaşılmalar olduğu için
dedim ki ben Avukat Feyza.
Ama Feyyaz dediler bana dedi.
Yanlış olmuş dedim ben Feyza,
başka avukat yok bu telefonda.
Dedi herhâlde yanlış oldu,
ben kapatıp tekrar arayayım.
Tamam bekliyorum, tekrar aradı
"Evet, evet Feyyaz'mış" dedi.
Dedim ki valla Feyyaz yok burada,
ben varım.
Avukatım, Doğan'da benim müvekkilim
benim numaramı size vereceğini biliyorum,
yani benim o.
"Allah Allah! dedi bu nasıl iş olur,
bana Feyyaz dediler,
iyi avukat dediler" dedi.
Yani inanmıyor, ben Feyza'yım ve
iyi avukat olamam.
Abartmıyorum, bunu gerçekten yaşadım.
Kapattı, ben müvekkilimi aradım dedim ki;
"Bak Doğan adam beni sinirlendiriyor,
arayın dedim, aramasın beni,
ben onun avukatı olmak istemiyorum."
Tekrar beni arıyor
"Bana Feyyaz'ı ver!" dedi.
(Gülüşmeler)
Yedim Feyyaz'ı dedim ben de, yok Feyyaz.
Adam inanmıyor.
Yine seneler önce Amerika'ya gideceğim,
o zaman ki erkek arkadaşıma;
"Ben Amerika'ya gideceğim" dedim.
"Gidemezsin" dedi.
"Neden?" dedim.
"Özlerim, mesafe uzak"
romantik bir şey bekliyorum ben de.
"Orada zenciler var" dedi.
(Gülüşmeler)
Hacı dedim zenciler sana ne yaptı?
"Sen ne demek istiyorsun?" dedi.
Bilmiyorum sen ne demek istiyorsun,
ben de onu demek istiyorum sana dedim.
Ya işte kafa bu.
Samimi söylüyorum toplumun kafası bu.
Gerçekten ahlak sorguladığımızda, ahlak
var mı yok mu söylemeyeceğim
ama ahlakçılık var.
Bu ahlakçılık kadın bedeni
üzerinden gidiyor.
Ben kabul etmiyorum,
ben yan görev kabul etmiyorum.
Niye bir hükûmet kurulduğu zaman Aile ve
Sosyal Politikalar Bakanı kadın oluyor?
Niye Adalet Bakanı, Ekonomi Bakanı,
Maliye bakanı, Dışişleri Bakanı
kadın olmuyor?
Neden sadece yan görevler?
(Alkışlar)
Belediye Başkanı oluyorsun, Başkan
Yardımcısı'nı kadın yapıyorsun ne güzel!
Nesi güzel?
Ben Belediye Başkanı olmak istiyorum.
Niye müsteşar oluyorum,
Başbakan olmuyorum?
Neden bana eşit şartlar
sunulmuyor iş hayatında?
Ben kabul etmiyorum,
ben yan görev kabul etmiyorum.
Bugün duruşmada ben gözümle gördüm.
Kadın geldi, hâkim kadın
''Hâkim bey'' diyor.
Bakıyorum kadına,
kadın hâkime hâkim bey diyor.
O hâkim, hâkimse bey olur ancak,
hâkime hanım olamaz.
Biliyor ya da bilmiyor o ayrı mesele
ama bu böyle gerçekten.
Ben bunun kırılmasını istiyorum.
Bakın ben demiyorum ki, erkeklere böyle
yapıyorsanız kızlara da öyle yapın.
Adil olunsun.
Edepse herkese edep.
Ben edepliyim, sen edepli değilsen
senin edepsizliğin beni niye etkiliyor ki?
Ben niye senin yüzünden sokağa çıkmıyorum.
Ben de gece 3'te gezmeyi en az bir
erkek kadar hak ediyorum.
Kimse bunu kısıtlayamaz.
(Alkışlar)
Ben istediğimi giyerim arkadaş.
Sen kendi gözüne bakacaksın.
Sen kendi nefsine bakacaksın.
Ben sonuçta bu toplumu provoke edecek,
insanları kışkırtacak,
toplumun huzurunu bozacak şeyler
yapmıyoruz biz bu ülkede kadınlar olarak.
Biz mutlu olmak istiyoruz.
Biz kendimiz olmak istiyoruz.
Bize bir şey dayatmadan,
bizi sıkmadan, bizi bunaltmadan.
Biz gerçekten var olmak istiyoruz.
Bana dayatılan bütün yasaklara,
yapamazsınlara.
Bana neler söylediler;
Olmaz, yapamazsın,
edemezsin, yapmamalısın.
Yaparım!
Sen kimsin ki?
Senin benden ne özelliğin var?
Bu mu?
Yok kardeşim hiç bir önemi yok benim için.
(Alkışlar)
Ben bir kadınım.
Eksik ya da yarım olduğumu
düşünmüyorum bu hâlimle.
(Alkışlar)
Beni bütünleyen şey bir koca,
bir çocuk, bir evlilik de değil.
Bunlar ancak doğru yer, doğru zaman
ve doğru insanla beni mutlu eden,
hayatımı paylaştığım bir kurum.
Yanımda bir insan, evladım olabilir.
Bunlar beni bütünlemez.
Ben kocasız da varım.
Ben çocuksuz da tümüm.
Ben kariyerimle, işimle, aşklarımla,
hırslarımla, tutkularımla,
ruhumla, görüntümle, cinselliğimle,
istediklerimle ve istemediklerimle
bir kadınım.
Varım, tümüm, var olacağım.
Kimse bana eksiksin, yarımsın,
yapamazsın, edemezsin diyerek
beni asla engelleyemezler bu ülkede.
Ben iddia ediyorum,
bizim atasözlerimiz bile kadınları
aşağılar, erkekleri över nitelikte.
"Karı gibi ağlama" derler mesela.
"Erkek gibi erkek," "Adam gibi adam,"
"Adamın dibi"
ya da bir kadını övmek için bile
"Erkek gibi kadın" derler.
Ben kadın gibi kadınım.
Erkeklik sizin olsun.
Erkekliğe bu ülkede
çok fazla şey atfediliyor.
Ben kötü olduğu için söylemiyorum.
Ne demek istediğimi çok iyi ifade
edebiliyor muyum bilmiyorum ama
anlaşıldığımı düşünmek istiyorum.
Erkeklikle ilgili bir sorunum yok.
Erkekliği överken, kadınlığın bu şekilde
yerden yere vurulmasıyla sorunum var.
Bu coğrafyada kadın olmak direnç demek.
Kadın olmak mücadele etmek demek.
Kadın olmak belki 5 katı, belki 10 katı
çaba göstermek demek.
Yapmadığın şeyler için bile yaftalanma
korkusuyla yaşamak demek bu coğrafyada.
O yüzden erkeklik çok onurlu,
çok gururlu vesaire olabilir.
Sizin onurunuz, gururunuz
sizi ilgilendiriyor.
Ben bir kadın olarak kadın gibi,
kadınlık onuru ve kadınlık gururumla
yaşıyorum bu ülkede.
Böyle yaşayacağım
ve eğer erkek olarak cesareti olan varsa
gelsin Türkiye'de kadın olarak yaşasın.
Meydan okuyorum ben!
Ciddi söylüyorum.
(Alkışlar)
Size çok samimi söylüyorum,
ben bu ülkede sevişti diye kızının
kemiklerini kırarak,
bir sağlam kemik bırakmayarak
döven baba gördüm.
Biz burada bir grup olarak
birbirimizi anlıyor olabiliriz.
Ben rahatlıkla bunları
konuşuyor olabilirim.
Bu ülkede eline halat verip
kendini öldüreceksin ya da biz seni
öldüreceğiz diyen kadınlar var.
Hâlâ intihar gibi gözüken
çözemediğimiz dosyalar var.
Bu ülkede güldü diye, sokakta
biriyle flört etti diye dövülen,
öldürülen, asılan kadınlar var.
Her gün görüyoruz haberlerde, değil mi?
Gerçekten biz, insanların
kadınlık onurlarının
ve gururunun bu ülkede olduğunu
düşünmüyoruz.
Ama bunun artık anlaşılması, bilinmesi ve
algılanması gerektiğini düşünüyorum.
Biz bundan sonra kadın
olarak ölmeyeceğiz,
yaşayacağız, kahkaha atacağız,
sevişeceğiz,
güleceğiz, çocuklar doğuracağız eğer
istersek, istemezsek doğurmayacağız.
Çalışmaz istersek çalışacağız.
Çalışmak istemiyorsak, artık nasıl
yaşayacağız onu bilmiyorum
-çalışmak lazım çünkü-
ama bir şekilde o hâlledilir
diye düşünüyorum
Biz bu şekilde var olacağız.
Bizi bu şekilde kabul edin.
Kabul etmek zorundasınız.
Etmeyenler olursa ettireceğiz.
Mücadeleye devam edeceğiz.
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkışlar)